in the middle of a debris field the
smell of burning Carriage is still in
the air
repair work is underway to restore vital
rail links
less than 24 hours after a passenger
Train derailed outside of the town of
Sahari in southern Sindh province
saluted with belongings of the men women
and children among the injured and dead
nearby villagers were the first to
arrive at the crash site
people were crying and screaming stuck
inside the train cars we could hear them
screaming so we broke open the doors and
brought them out one train car was
nearly folded in half another now sits
by a bridge at the point of impact
the severity of the damage tells us how
terrifying it must have been for the
people inside this train car terrifying
final moments Witnesses tell us other
than maybe one or two people almost no
one made it out of this train car alive
zarmina lost her husband and son in the
crash
her daughters are recovering in
intensive care
she says she cannot cry in front of them
because they still don't know their
father and brother did not survive
I can't get my husband or son back I'm
from a poor family and I have no one
else who can help me now I will have to
take care of my daughters alone the
government should help us
derailments like this critics say are
all too common in Pakistan
people blame years of neglect and an
aging Railway system in urgent need of
better safety standards and
modernization
the railway system should be improved
there's been so Much Death it's a very
big tragedy the railway line should be
properly maintained the lines are nearly
150 years old
the government has announced financial
compensation for survivors and the
families of the Dead
immediate relief that will no doubt be
helpful for low-income families but a
Band-Aid on a much bigger problem Zain
Bas raviol Jazeera sarhari Sindh
Pakistan